welcome to Hari seulbi's the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into the newest tech products
so recently the gtx 1060 hits all-time
low in 2018 and a hit into to hundreds
so does this mean that you guys should
buy the gtx 1060 or wait a little bit
longer for prices to drop even more or
even wait for the 1100 series but before
we discuss that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs first of
all before deciding whether or not to
buy the gtx 1060 right now you guys
should consider the future price
projection of the gtx 1060 even though
the fall has been very slow for the gtx
1060 the price has been consistently
dropping for the last couple of months
and a price will most likely continue to
drop for the next couple of months until
it finally reaches MSRP so how long till
the gtx 1060 finally reaches MSRP well
for the last couple of months on average
the gtx 1060 has dropped by $30.00 in
price every single month at the
beginning of march the gtx 1066 gigabyte
card costed 385 dollars by the end of
that month it had dropped $25 all the
way down to 360
during April it dropped another 4
dollars bringing a price down to 320
dollars and throughout May it dropped
another $30 which finally brought down
the price to 290 dollars which is what
it costs right now so based on that and
considering that the MSRP of the gtx
1066 gigabyte card is 250 dollars we
should expect the gtx 1060 to reach MSRP
around mid-july also there is nothing
holding it back from reaching MSRP like
inflate a demand or not enough stock so
it should reach MSRP so overall if you
guys wait one more month before you buy
the gtx 1066 gigabyte card you guys can
save around 40 to 50 dollars another
thing to consider before buying the gtx
1060 is how it will perform in the
future like in three to five years well
the performance Doby good well right now
the gtx 1066 gigabyte card is on
arguably the best 1080p 60 FPS gaming
sweet spot it can handle all modern
games at Ultra settings at a solid 60fps
at 1080p but will it be able to do that
same thing in three to five years well
unfortunately games are consistently
becoming more detailed and graphically
intense and so in three to five years if
you want to keep your GTX 1060 then you
probably have to download the settings
down to high instead of Ultron some
games but for the most part the GTX 1066
gigabyte card should still perform
really well so if you want to keep your
graphics card for around three to five
years then you may want to consider
getting the gtx 1070 if you don't want
to download under graphics in a couple
of years if you're fine with that then
the GTX 1060 is still a really great
option finally the last thing to
consider before buying the GTX 1060 is
invidious next generation of graphics
cards I have dedicated videos on the
performance price and release date of
the 1100 series so if you guys are
interested in that then make sure to
check that out but here's a rundown of
it the gtx 1116 will probably come out
for an MSRP of around 250 dollars just
like the gtx 1060 and it will come out
at the end of this year or at the very
beginning of 2019 and for the
performance it'll just be barely better
than the performance of the gtx 1070 and
on top of this you'll get GD r6 memory
beyond the 12 nanometer process and
beyond latest architecture so is that
all worth it while in my opinion if you
can wait then it is definitely worth it
because for the same price you are
getting an extra level of GPU
performance and all the new technologies
that come along with the gtx 1160 also
are you okay with buying an almost
outdated card which is the gtx 1060 you
might want to consider that as well
before going on to purchase however I do
understand that the release date after
gtx 1160 is around 6 months away from
right now so for many of you guys that
may be too long of a wait especially
because you guys have already been
waiting for many many
for the prices to come down so for you
guys something else to consider is
instead of waiting for the GTX 1160
which is coming at the end of the year
you can actually wait for the GTX at
eleven seventy and eleven eighty which
are coming out in about three months so
when the GTX 1170 and eleven eighty come
out the price of the GTX 1070 will most
likely go down and as a result if you
guys save some more money in that time
period you may be able to afford the gtx
1070 that way you can upgrade to the
next GPU level and not spend too much
more money as well and on top of that
you guys will be more future proof for
the next couple of years so here's the
verdict the gtx 1066 gigabyte card is
the absolute sweet spot for 1080p gaming
and is going to hit MSRP very soon most
likely next month however it will most
likely struggle a little bit to handle
the newer games at full settings so if
you guys want to play the newest games
of ultra settings for the next couple of
years you may want to consider buying
the gtx 1070 however if you're ok with
dying down the graphics level from ultra
to high for the next couple of years for
some games then the gtx 1060 is still a
great option but in my opinion i think
the best option is to wait with the gtx
1160 but it's going to provide a
significant performance upgrade for the
same price and you will be on latest
architecture and have the new
technologies associated with it if you
can't wait that long then something else
to consider is buying the gtx 1070 once
the gtx 1170 and 1180 come out for a
really good discounted price but that's
just what i think what do you guys think
do you guys think that's worth waiting
for the gtx 1160 or what do you think
about the gtx 1170 and 1180 are you guys
excited for those make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video then make sure to drop a
like on it and hit that subscribe button
if you guys would like to see more
videos just like this almost every
single day but until next time bye
[Music]